[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
la parole est au président Laurent la
font pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur il y a quelques
semaines vous annonciez ici même au
Sénat que des festivals devront être
annulés durant l'été 2024 à cause des
Jeux Olympiques cette annonce a provoqué
de nombreuses réactions
d'incompréhension la semaine dernière
avec plus d'une trentaine de sénateurs
et sénatrice membre de la commission
culture éducation et communication du
Sénat nous avons publié dans le journal
Le Monde une tribune pour dire que le JO
ne peuvent se faire au détriment des
nombreuses manifestations sportives
culturelles festives qui ont lieu
traditionnellement partout en France
madame la ministre de la Culture a dans
un interview publié aujourd'hui dans le
journal Le Parisien précisé que des
solutions avaient été trouvées
pratiquement avec les tous les grands
festivals en tout cas ceux qui recourent
aux unités de force mobile tant mieux
néanmoins de nombreuses questions
demeure quid des grands événements
festifs qui ont lieu dans un certain
nombre de régions françaises durant
l'été je pense en particulier au
sud-ouest de la France avec des fêtes
comme celle de Bayonne ou de Dax quid de
la surveillance des plages qui jusqu'à
présent sont assurés par des CRS quidd
enfin des nombreux événements qui pour
se tenir ont besoin des de recourir aux
sociétés de sécurité privée on le sait
les JO vont massivement faire appel à
ces sociétés plus de 15000
postes doivent être créés pour faire
face au seul besoin des Jeux Olympiques
ces sociétés pourront-elles couvrir à la
fois les besoins des événements en
province et ce lier aux Jeux olympiques
et dans ces conditions monsieur le
ministre pourquoi ne pas compléter le
dispositif en recourant à l'armée
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald
Darmanin
les Jeux Olympiques à Paris c'est une
fois par siècle
et les Jeux Olympiques à Paris avec une
cérémie d'Hercule en dehors d'un stade
c'est une fois tous les 3000 ans parce
que personne ne l'a jamais organisé en
dehors d'un stade et je pense que l'on
peut constater ensemble l'intérêt
général qui est de réussir je vous en ai
particulièrement sensible je le sais les
Jeux olympiques de Paris et les Jeux
paralympiques qui s'étale durant l'été
2024 après d'ailleurs qu'en 2024 c'est
aussi le 80e anniversaire du
débarquement de Normandie ce qu'il y a
qu'au mois de juin également il y aura
énormément de force des forces sécurité
intérieure pour protéger l'ensemble de
ces grands événements avec tous ces
chefs d'État et bien sûr cette grande
familiature à Paris ce que vous en
proposez avec la ministre de la Culture
avec la ministre des Sports en charge
des Jeux Olympiques ce n'est pas
l'annulation des événements c'est leur
décalage notamment dans l'OTAN et je
crois que nous avons été en partie
entendu
par exemple le Tour de France qui ne va
pas arriver en 2024 à Paris et le 28
juillet mais à Nice le 21 juillet voilà
quelque chose qui nous paraît conforme à
l'intérêt général et conforme à la
volonté d'avoir évidemment un tour de
France en 2024 ou le festival des
Vieilles Charrues je peux aussi parler
du Festival d'Avignon et d'autres grands
festivals dont madame la ministre de la
Culture à l'occasion d'évoquer un
décalage de dates pour les Vieilles
Charrues elle se déroulant du 11 au 14
juillet au lieu du 18 au 21 juillet
comme quoi il est on est capable dans
notre pays de discuter en concertation
avec tous les acteurs du monde sportif
et culturel au niveau de festif en
général pour que ces événements se
tiennent mais dans des conditions où on
doit comprendre qu'il faut 45 000
policiers et gendarmes pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris des années
d'ouverture jusqu'à sa fin en ce qui
concerne l'armée elle est déjà très
largement mobilisée si l'armée ne tenait
pas par exemple le site qui ferait
partir les bateaux sur la barge ce
serait 30 ufm que nous serons obligés
d'utiliser par les forces de l'ordre
l'armée c'est aussi ceux qui gardent la
politique aérienne se autorité de la
première ministre les lutte antidrone ou
contre l'arrivée de d'avion par exemple
au-dessus de nos événements mais l'armée
n'est pas fait pour les matières de
l'ordre voilà plus d'un siècle que nous
avons de spécialisé cela grâce à un
certain nombre de policiers et de
gendarmes ce n'est pas pour les confier
à la va-vite il faut conclure à des
militaires on aura l'occasion d'en
parler la sécurité privée on en fait le
ministre de du travail un certain nombre
de démarches très positif qui nous
permet d'être confiant dans la présence
de sécurité privée partout sur le
territoire national tu es le président
Lafont
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur ministre pour ces
éléments de réponse
n'avons pas forcément compris la façon
dont la question des festivals avait été
abordée jusqu'à présent vous faites une
annonce et quelques semaines après on
nous annonce que finalement les
solutions étaient trouvées dont acte
étant mieux mais pour éviter que ces
solutions ne se reproduisent nous
souhaiterions notamment qu'au niveau des
territoires et avec les élus locaux nous
fassiez un inventaire précis des
manifestations et que vous abordiez
concrètement quelles solutions peuvent
être trouvées dans un contexte on le
sait et vous l'avez rappelé qui est
exceptionnel avec les difficultés que
peuvent engendrer l'organisation des
manifestations aussi importante que
celle des JO néanmoins le dialogue avec
les élus locaux sur ce point nous sommes
extrêmement importants
merci
[Musique]